hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com so many people have
been interested in the petrov defense
lately it got me thinking
i should definitely make a video on the
immortal game
of alexander petrov who is the
individual that the petrov defense is
named after now petrov if you're not
familiar with him lived in the 1700
1800 time frame russian chess master for
50 years
he was the number one chess player in
russia which is a long time knowing that
there's so many good players
coming out of russia in 1844 he's
playing an individual
play by the name of alexander hoffman
another chess master both these players
in warsaw at the time that they played
this match but white's going to be
played by alexander hoffman and black's
going to be played by
alexander petrov hoffman starts out with
e4 and then e5 from petrov knight to f3
and you can already see has the
potential to play knight f6 but instead
decides to play
knight to c6 bishop to c4 the italian
game
bishop to c5 getting into the gioco
piano and then c3 this is the main line
preparing for
d4 trying to control the center of the
board for whites
also has different options here you can
always play the evans game but
sacrificing that pawn and material
maybe the bishop comes back here to a5
and then you push forward with d4 this
is the
common theme that white's looking to do
is play c3 and then
push forward with d4 and that's the same
thing in the main line of c3
next move of d4 here and we see petrov
play
knight to f6 and then d4 pawn takes here
on d4 and then hoffman has
couple options you have the main line
which same as what we talked about pawn
takes here on d4
white has two central pawns compared to
black only has
one central pawn here so that's kind of
the main idea but hoffman goes for
also an extremely popular play and that
is
e5 now there's not as much theory in
this opening in 1844 so the fact that he
was able to find this move that
so many players play today is really
interesting to me when you just study
these old games and you find these lines
that these players were actually able to
find
back in the day pretty cool stuff to see
so pawn to
e5 and then from here
really you'll see most players playing
pawn to
d5 from black this is attacking the
bishop right here
says hey if you want to take this knight
that's fine we'll go ahead and take that
bishop
but instead we see petrov playing knight
to e4 then a pretty interesting move in
the game and that is bishop to
d5 because this really is almost
baiting this knight here on e4 to take
on f2 if we start to look at how black
can really
move this knight here on e4 okay well it
can't just come back here to d6 or
f6 that's being protected by this pawn
here on e5
it can't come here to g5 because white
has both the bishop here and
the knight both attacking it so that's
not gonna work
okay we can clearly see that can't come
to c3
or d2 it's just going to fall so the
only real option is to play knight takes
here on f2 you can always try something
crazy
pawn to f5 trying to protect it but then
just the pawn takes here
controlling the center of the board two
central pawns
maybe bishop to b4 but then after a
bishop to d2
just what does black really have and
then
has a pretty exposed king side over here
without a really strong attack so i
don't think that's
a good option for black so in the game
petrov decides hey if you want to give
me that
knight takes here on f2 we'll go ahead
and down go down that path so knight
takes on f2
and then king takes here on f2
now black takes on c3 and part of the
reason
you may say why gobble up material uh
this is a discovered attack with the
bishop here on c5 the entire reason you
would give up your knight here on f2
is one to expose the king and then two
to really have a strong attack so
if you're gonna do this you have to be
pretty aggressive which petrov
uh definitely intends to do for his
immortal game so the king comes to g3
could also just come back to
the first rank here both are fine from
white's perspective
and then pawn takes here on b2 attacking
the rook and the bishop essentially
forcing white to do something here
and part of the the reason that you want
to do this
is to get this dark square bishop off of
this diagonal right here so uh
definitely
something that white has to keep in mind
as far as where his material is
and then how he's going to defend some
of the attacks that black has
on board so next move is knight to e7
this is both attacking this bishop here
on
d5 but more importantly it's coming up
here to
f5 attacking the king here on
g3 now white plays the move knight to
g5 and the thought really is here okay
if you want to
take with the knight here on d5
well now then the knight's gonna come
down to f7
this is attacking the queen really not
just going to lose your queen so you're
probably going to take with your king
here on
f7 and then queen takes here on d5
check and then after the king moves the
queen takes here on c5
both players are playing extremely high
level and they just say okay that was a
pretty fun exchange here
let's see how the end of the game goes
and then they just kind of give each
other a nod and things continue but
petrov had other plans after knight
takes here on f7
he has no intention of taking this
knight here on f7
he intends to give up this queen here on
d8 so he decides to go ahead and castle
on the king side
so yeah go ahead and take my queen here
on d8 which hoffman does he takes knight
takes on
d8 and then bishop to f2 now this is
check and you can start to see
the threat here this king can't come to
the ephile because of the rook
can't take the bishop because of the
rook it can't come to
h4 and so really the only options are
g4 and h3
but either one can so he decides to go
to h3 but then
pawn to d6 and now the light square
bishop and gets involved into the game
with a check here so now pawn to
e6 knight to f4
and you can see this is one of the
reasons why you want to play that pawn
to
b2 attacking the rook on
a1 here and it got that bishop off of
the dark square diagonal so really
thinking ahead as far as how he wanted
to attack says yeah
ha if you want to just give me that rook
that's fine
if you just want to give me a free pawn
that's fine as well but you probably
need to take and that's going to set up
a threat
later down in the game so after knight 2
f4
check king 2 g4 and then knight
takes here on e6 and while this is not
check it's
it's gearing up for a strong attack
coming on the next move from black white
decides to go ahead and take here on e6
there's no real good move
for white black really has all the
momentum here and there's no way to stop
it but decides to go ahead and
play here on e6 and then bishop takes
here on e6
king to g5 rook up here to f5
it is all forced from here king to g4
pawn to h5 king to h3
and then rook to f3 checkmate pretty
cool
checkmate you usually don't see the
bishop coming down here on f2
and then having the king just be chased
around
on the king side of the board in the
middle of the board
with bishops and a rook so
really exciting game from alexander
petrov did the whole thing
in 20 moves so it's nice to have an
immortal game
and get through such a fun variation
with
only 20 moves so really cool hopefully
you guys
enjoyed this video i always like looking
at some of these older immortal games
and seeing how people approach the game
and seeing the variations that they went
down uh so thanks for watching i'll see
you guys
in the next video